[Music]
remember a member of the fifth of
November
Sainsbury's has lost the plot I see no
reason why animal appeasing means
fireworks should not be got it emerged
this week at the supermarket have
stopped selling fireworks in their
stores a decision welcomed by animal
charities who say the 45% of dogs show
signs of fear when they hear rockets now
I love dogs more than people I trust
them and I know somebody whose dog won't
go outside at night because he was
terrified by fireworks once but to ban
fireworks which might cause the stress
to some animals while literally selling
the dead flesh of those who had
slaughtered for human consumption is
insane keep your dogs indoors
create hiding places for your cats
microchip them in case they run away and
at risk of sounding a little bit like
Nick Ferrari what virtue signalling
vacuous Ness we're not a quiet species
the most beautiful things in the world
are often bright and noisy let's do what
we can to shield the animals we love but
I mean come on
it's so pretty well I actually I was
agreeing with you but then you lost me
when you started talking about animal
flesh and all the rest of it but I don't
agree with fireworks being banned but I
think that we need to be really clear
Sainsbury's isn't stopping selling
fireworks in order to protect animals or
stop anti-social behavior they are doing
it purely and simply for commercial
reasons there was a there was a leaked
email to employees that basically said
that they've done their commercial
reviews and it doesn't make sense
basically the studies they reviewed the
sales performances and the associated
operating constants for that reason
they've decided to stop selling them I'm
just gonna fart in and then throw back
to you this is what Sanders actually
said to inform the debate fireworks are
no longer available in our stores but
customers can continue to choose from a
range of seasonal products such as glow
sticks and light up spinning ones we
regularly review the products available
in our stores this is based on a range
of factors as I was saying make no
mistake about it these stores are
this to create a profit and if they are
using very valuable floor space because
don't be fooled every inch of their
floors in these kind of stores are
calculated for how they can maximize
their profit if they have got something
that isn't selling they will be very
quick to remove it so whilst people are
jumping on the bandwagon and saying this
is wonderful Sainsbury's and you're
protecting the animals I would just
advance a slight word of caution about
their potential motive actually one of
the main things is that the shops cannot
return fireworks they can't get their
money back on so that's one of the
reasons I mean I would I love a firework
I do I love that even now at my advanced
age I still go whoo I love the colors
it's party time when this way I love
however I love but but what I think is I
do see the effect it has on animals and
I know it's not even just household pets
the ones that because we can protect
them what we can't protect all the ones
outside the ones in the farms and and
there was a terrible story from Arkansas
in 2010 on New Year's Eve 5,000
red-winged blackbirds fell out of the
sky dead because they'd that stop me
this is important this is just one
example there are many of them because
they're terrible at bats in Arkansas
what happens in this country is animals
wander deer run into the roof they get
killed Capitol panic they die of heart
attacks we could fit the solution to all
of this and don't laugh there's a thing
called a quiet fire
it's about spectacle and there's even a
village in this dish for collection
cycle and fireworks are the way forward
there's a ledge in Italy and they've
banned proper fireworks and they have
think you all have already seen quiet
fireworks you see them already there's
one called a comet's tail which is the
one that sizzles love it into the sky
there's one called a flying fish and
that's brilliant tiny tad pill things
stop taking the mick you're taking the
mickey and if you're gonna save the
lives of a lot of livestock you can you
can have these instead of big banging
the people who are post I mean this
we've got a clip from someone from the
British Association of Aesthetic Plastic
Surgeons called Carole
I'm paid and she says a lot of people
are injured fireworks confirm locally
they can cause severe burns when your
clothes are on fire they can cause
blindness when they go off in your face
and they can cause life-changing
injuries especially to your limbs I mean
what we shouldn't do is I mean when when
I was young and you were fairly young
we remember I mean you people as kids we
all bought fireworks they sue bang is
everywhere I never forget a mate of mine
through a banger and someone saw a bag
of fireworks please try this at home
and I think that it would be wrong to go
back to those days but I like fun I like
fireworks demonstrations I think they
are brilliant I think London on New
Year's Eve is sensational and I hate
that we stopped let's stop
not having fun we should be celebrating
as family rightly says okay it is very
sad so make sure your animals are looked
after if you can get the cattle into a
shed the bats in Arkansas I just don't
watch it in and boy in a week or so time
it's gonna be Halloween in a week's time
around a week's time it's going to be
Halloween and we've already been told
that we shouldn't be eating pumpkins and
it's nice and we all get dressed up in
fancy dress nice of you to come early by
the way very good and we shouldn't have
pumpkins because we should then be
making pumpkin fritters and pumpkins
let's just enjoy life is bloody top a
little the way people handle fireworks
it shows I think people are much more
responsible with them now you know but I
and I would hate to see you know the
best one I have on bonfire night is my
all our gardens lead on and I can see
little kids four or five year old with a
mom and dad in the back garden it's a
lovely thing I don't want to go but it
could be a quiet fun okay so on the
issue of quiet fireworks no way stop
there why not have quiet music concerts
have everybody Europe you're right here
people do offer orphan or responsible I
remember me personally I got an
internally suspended at school because I
set fire to a tennis ball at on dear
ving it got kicked over a row of tension
before they all make you look very bad I
know I was a very naughty boy but as for
there are regulations I mean you've got
the Department of Business and Energy
who have said that there are already
strict regulations legislation to
regulate and support the supply of story
to possession and use of and whose
misuse of fireworks to ensure Public
Safety this is something that exists
already
oh by the way let's just be sensible
she's talking about blindness and loss
of limbs and all the rest of it you're
gonna be a bit dim if you think about
picking up a unlit firework or a
discarded fire leave them alone act
responsibly and just get on when he did
a few years ago was a bunch of firewood
he told me and he told what you told us
a story they said you didn't want to
repeat on air as well I did so a few wit
fireworks onto a bonfire and it did
create chaos and I wouldn't advise
anybody to ever do it but I do love
going to the difference today is that
they are about organized displays as
whereas when we were kids you used to
get your own bonfire you try and steal
the mattress of the bonfire up the road
have your own bonfire your own fireworks
and they were lovely well I'm gonna
leave you lots reminisce about your
favorite bands and I'm gonna move on
it's one small step for a woman but one
giant leap for womankind that's right
forget Neil and Buzz there's two astro
sisters making history with their moon
boots NASA astronauts Christina Kirk and
Jessica Mayer sure does women can do it
just as well if not better than men when
they took part in the first ever
all-female spacewalk last week the pair
spent more than seven hours in the
vacuum of space as they worked to
replace a broken battery charger on the
outside of the International Space
Station here's what Jessica to say after
there had completed the walk I will
never forget that moment coming out the
hatch and looking down and seeing just
my boots and the earth below and it was
such a spectacular and beautiful sight
it's real it was really quite
overwhelming
we went out and did the job that we had
to do and we're lucky enough to have
some time to enjoy the view as well safe
to say Houston was never going to have a
problem with these two in charge for
making it to infinity and beyond Jessica
and Christina you are are astronomical
astronauts of the week it's interesting
there wasn't it that all they were doing
up there was was they were fixing a
broken battery chargers I think the
matter had if it had been a man I
suspect the job would have been a bigger
one don't you all I was looking at that
is thinking their hair look like how you
look when you were a Viking that you
make some comments so I'm too smart I'm
going to actually read something I'm not
getting involved in the great debate
right that's all we've got time for this
week but don't forget you can join in
the debate by searching for the pledge
on Twitter and you can also listen for
the program on the go with the pledge
podcast just subscribe using whatever
app you prefer thanks for watching and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you